on july 7th 2021 steve ballmer's net
worth
officially surged past 100 billion
dollars
making him the ninth individual to join
the center billionaire club
all of his peers have one thing in
common they founded the top companies
in the world whether that be google and
facebook or oracle
and amazon but steve is unlike anyone
else at the top
not only did steve not found a major
company
but he also didn't make any unbelievable
investments
like investing into bitcoin in 2009 or
investing in amazon during the dotcom
crash
for the most part steve was just at the
right place
at the right time so here's how steve
ballmer was able to make
100 billion dollars working at nine to
five
taking a look back steve ballmer was
born on march 24
1956 in detroit michigan he was the son
of an immigrant family from switzerland
and his dad was a manager at ford though
steve never started his own company
he definitely had the intelligence for
it from a very young age
steve attended a college preparatory
school called detroit country day school
where he graduated as valedictorian
aside from graduating at the top of his
class
steve also aced sad scoring a perfect
800 on the math section
nowadays these achievements are
basically prerequisites to even be
considered by harvard
but back in 1973 harvard's missions were
much more reasonable
and steve was admitted into the class of
1977.
at harvard steve majored and applied
mathematics and economics
in his free time he worked on the school
newspaper and even served as a manager
for the harvard crimson football team
but by far the most important part of
his undergraduate studies was becoming
friends with a young man
named bill gates at the time bill gates
was just about to drop out and start
microsoft
some reports suggest that bill even
asked steve to drop out with them and be
a leading voice at microsoft
but steve preferred to stick to the safe
path and finish out his degree at
harvard
i don't think anyone can blame him for
this decision i mean
who cared about personal computers in
1975.
anyway after bill gates dropped out
steve and bill started to pursue
radically different paths for a couple
of years
while bill went all in on microsoft
steve continued his academic excellence
graduating magna laude in 1977
after graduation steve landed a solid
job as a project manager
at procter and gamble he would only work
there for two years though
before he went back to school to get an
mba from stanford
during the following summer steve would
approach bill gates wondering if he
could get a summer job at microsoft
though steve just wanted a summer job
bill wanted a much bigger commitment
from steve
bill asked steve to drop out of stanford
and become microsoft's first full-time
manager
steve was unwilling to take the leap of
faith five years ago
but now he was in a much more secure
position
he had a harvard degree under his belt a
couple of years of experience at procter
and gamble
and he only had one year left on the
stanford mba
so even if microsoft failed steve
wouldn't have any trouble finding a high
paying job elsewhere
despite this his parents were actually
still quite worried about him pursuing
microsoft
when steve told his parents about bill's
offer his dad said
what the heck is software and his mom
said why would a person ever need a
computer
as you can see steve's parents weren't
quite convinced about microsoft
but steve would nonetheless go ahead and
join microsoft on june 11th 1980.
this made steve the 30th employee at
microsoft where he earned a salary of 50
per year that's the same as 163 000
today more than a solid salary though
bill promised you five to ten percent
equity in the future
on paper steve was a business manager at
microsoft
but according to steve he was basically
bill's personal assistant
apparently he did everything from hiring
new employees to cooking and washing
bottles
steve's breakout moment wasn't far
behind though later in 1980
microsoft would have a monumental
meeting with ibm and
bill would ask steve to come along to
the meeting this wasn't some
super smart strategic move or anything
like that though apparently
steve was the only guy who knew how to
wear a tie his presence however
would prove to be much more useful you
see it neither bill gates nor paul allen
really had any experience negotiating
contracts or forming partnerships
steve didn't have much experience
himself but he was the most experience
of the bunch
during negotiations with ibm the trio
were able to include
one game-changing clause into the
contract with ibm which was
non-exclusivity
ibm would pay microsoft 430 000 to
develop ms-dos
but since the deal was non-exclusive
microsoft could turn around and sell the
software to other computer manufacturers
as well now ibm wasn't stupid
and they didn't get duped by a couple of
young businessmen the reason they agreed
to the non-exclusive deal was because
they themselves were being investigated
for monopolistic practices
so they let the non-exclusivity with
microsoft slide
between 1981 and 1985 bill gates would
get to work on the technical side of
ms-dos
meanwhile steve ballmer would get to
work on the business side of ms-dos
selling it to several computer
manufacturers this grew microsoft
revenue from 16 million dollars in 1981
to 140 million dollars in 1985. clearly
hiring steve was a great move and bill
would deliver on his promise
awarding steve a person equity in the
company when the company went to public
in 1986
microsoft would be valued at 780 million
dollars at the end of the first trading
day
bill gates 45 stake was worth 350
million dollars
and paul allen's 25 stake was worth 195
while those are awesome amounts it's not
that surprising given that they were the
founders
steve ballmer didn't boast a stake as
large as bill and paul
but his eight percent stake translated
to a whopping 51.5 million dollars
he had only worked at microsoft for six
years at the time
meaning that he basically earned upwards
of 10 million dollars per year
i'm sure his parents were much more
convinced about microsoft after this
but this was just the beginning after
all
steve wasn't even worth 0.1 percent of
how much he's worth today
so let's get back to his story now that
the formative days of microsoft were
over
steve took on more traditional corporate
roles over the next six years
he led various divisions and served in
many manager and director roles
it wasn't until 1992 that steve
officially became an executive
as he took on the role of vice president
of sales and support
during his time as vp his most important
contribution was leading the development
of the net framework
after six years as vice president steve
would be promoted to president of
microsoft in july of 1998
making him second in command after bill
gates and once bill gates stepped down
as microsoft ceo at the turn of the
millennium
steve ballmer would reach the pinnacle
of his career taking on the role of
microsoft ceo
in january of 2000. unfortunately steve
ballmer would become known
as one of the most useless ceos out
there but
i don't really think this is true
everyone who talks down on steve ballmer
mainly just points out the stagnation of
microsoft stock over the next 14 years
and the various goofy moments of steve
now
let's be honest he had a lot of goofy
moments
here he is repeating the word developers
one too many times
developers developers developers
developers
and here's a clip of steve going
ballistic on stage
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen steve balmer
and yes steve did laugh at the launch of
the iphone
500 fully subsidized with a plan i said
that is
the most expensive phone in the world
and it doesn't appeal to business
customers because it doesn't have a
keyboard which makes it not a very good
email machine
now it may sell very well or not i you
know but jokes aside steve was
actually just super passionate about
microsoft and
the lack of stock growth during his time
as ceo wasn't really his fault
you see bill gates literally handed over
microsoft to steve
at the peak of the dot-com bubble the
dot com crash
literally started two months after steve
took over in 2000
microsoft stock peaked at 58 per share
but
within just 12 months microsoft stock
crashed to just 21 dollars per share
so microsoft was down 63 from the highs
within the first year and a half
of steve's leadership and just as
microsoft stock started to recover
they got crushed by the financial crisis
down to 15
per share but fundamentally speaking
steve actually pushed microsoft forward
quite a bit first of all steve ballmer
was a massive proponent of the xbox
many executives in the company thought
that microsoft should stick to software
and that building a gaming console was
way out of whack
but steve ballmer stood strong in the
support for the xbox
and today the xbox is one of their most
successful products
similarly in 2010 it was under steve
bomber's leadership
that microsoft launched her cloud
service azure
azure is likely the number one project
that eventually allowed microsoft to
break out of stagnation
and grow exponentially over the past
five years
and though steve didn't see the
potential of the iphone he did see the
potential of several other projects
in 2007 for instance microsoft invested
240 million dollars into facebook
at the time the company was only worth
15 billion dollars
today they're worth a trillion dollars
but by far the clearest evidence that
steve had a positive effect on microsoft
was the bottom line during steve's time
as ceo
microsoft's revenue nearly tripled from
25 billion dollars
to 70 billion dollars and their profits
more than doubled
from 9.4 billion dollars to 22 billion
dollars
investors simply didn't realize the
positive impact of steve ballmer
until after he left anyway after steve
ballmer retired from microsoft in 2014
he would turn around and buy the la
clippers in may of 2014
for two billion dollars around the same
time steve ballmer
became the largest individual
shareholder of microsoft
over the past 30 years he had sold off
about half of his initial eight percent
stake
leaving him with a four percent stake in
microsoft but bill gates had been
selling his shares and diversifying
much faster today bill gates has shrunk
his position at microsoft from 45
percent
down to just 1.3 percent if bill gates
had held on to his entire stake
he'd be worth 900 billion dollars today
and
if the bomber never sold any of his take
he'd be worth 160 billion
today ironically if steve didn't sell
any of his shares
he'd be worth more than bill gates today
though steve has cut down his position
over the years
he's extremely proud of being
microsoft's largest individual
shareholder
and he thinks that microsoft is the best
company in the world
in fact he banned the clippers from
using apple products
and apparently he doesn't let any of his
family members use iphones
i think we'd all agree that his
enthusiasm on stage wasn't just for show
and that he definitely wasn't
exaggerating when he said
i have four words for you i
love this company yes
and that's how steve ballmer managed to
make an astounding 100 billion dollars
working at nine to five
what do you guys think about steve's
stage presence comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys agree that
the bomber was an underrated ceo
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one